- I just think it's very
important to kind of
accept your reality, you know,
and accept where you are, and, you know,
but you just have to keep on doing you.
I mean, despite what it
looks like, you know.
You're the man of the family,
you're the head of the family.
But are you?
It's where you are, you're
the head of the house,
you're not working, you're
not bringing in any money,
and that's tough, you know.
I don't love that.
- Yeah.
- But . . .
Yeah, well, I'm, yeah,
I'm, I'm gettin' there.
Baby steps.
- Very small steps.
Tiny, tiny, little steps for you.
Little, little, little,
little, little baby steps.
So small, so small.
- We're,
- Yeah.
- We're doin', we're doin' it.
- We're all doin' it
- We'll get there.
Everyone's got their own road, and
- We all have our own journey.
- and we have our own journey.
And you could get hit
by a bus tomorrow, so.
- I'm so glad you're here.
Oh, my God, I wanted to show you,
you are gonna die, this
will really cheer you up.
- [Jason] Yeah?
- Yeah, this is, I just want you,
just take a look at these photographs,
and just check out these pieces.
- Uh huh.
- These photographs.
- What am I lookin' at here?
- That is a landscape.
- Okay.
- Actually, you know,
gotta turn it that way.
So, tell me who you think took these.
- Who?
- They're the most brilliant--
- [Jason] Who do I think took these?
- Yeah, who took these photographs?
- I don't, I don't know.
- Ryder.
- A blind person?
- Ryder, my five year old.
- Oh, yeah, Ryder.
- He's five years old.
My son is five years old
and he is taking
- Yes, he is.
- These kinds of pictures.
This is the most brilliant,
the colors are just like--
- There's a shot of--
- These are the most
brilliant stuff.
- There's a shot
up your nose, there.
- Yeah, it is.
- Right up your nose,
- Yep.
- and then there's your teeth.
- He's just, what he frames, I don't even,
I wouldn't ever think to do that.
Is he not brilliant, and the kid's like,
just, he's brilliant, isn't he?
- Um, yeah, I don't,
I don't know if I'd
use the word brilliant.
Seems like he--
- What would you call him?
Like--
- You know, it's great that
your son knows how to
work a digital camera,
and, you know, I think he, I think he just
was snappin' the picture a lot, you know.
He was ba, ba, ba, ba, ba.
I'm not really sure--
- When the moment struck him.
Absolutely he was.
When--
- Yeah.
- When he saw something that he
wanted to frame up, and, yes.
- Yeah, I probably wouldn't
call them brilliant.
I wouldn't just throw that
world around, you know
- Can I have this back?
- [Jason] I'm sorry.
- You wouldn't, so, what then?
- [Jason] No, I'm just sayin' I, you know,
I don't know if it's brilliant.
- I don't wanna say this
in front of the kids,
you're being an asshole right now.
- Me?
- I think you're being kind of an asshole.
- You think I'm, you think
I'm being an asshole?
I'm not being an asshole.
I'm just saying, you asked
me if they were brilliant,
and I just, hey, no, they're not,
they're not that, they're not brilliant.
I reserve my use of the word brilliant
for different things,
you know, like a sunset,
or somebody who creates the AIDS vaccine.
- Okay.
- Okay?
- So.
- I just think, just because the word
has never been used to describe you
or your work, doesn't mean you can't be
generous with it when it's deserved, okay.
- Um, okay.
- And that's all I'm saying.
I don't want you to look at them again.
- Okay, you know, well maybe.
- Like you give me that back.
- Well, maybe I'll go out and take
a couple of shots of your cat's asshole.
- That was his sister.
(uptempo music)